[MUSIC]
>> WELCOME FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES TO RADCLIFFE
DAY 2015! I'M LIZ COHEN.
I'M DEAN OF THE RADCLIFFE INSTITUTE FOR ADVANCED
STUDY.
I'M DELIGHTED THAT YOU ARE JOINING US HERE
IN CAMBRIDGE AND MANY PEOPLE ONLINE.
AT RADCLIFFE, WE OFTEN SPEAK OF BEING A BIG
TENT BECAUSE OF OUR COMMITMENT TO GENERATING
AND SHARING IDEAS ACROSS THE ARTS, HUMANITIES,
SCIENCES, AND SOCIAL SCIENCES.
AND BECAUSE WE ENGAGE WITH EVERYONE FROM STUDENTS
TO FELLOWS, TO FACULTY, TO THE BROAD PUBLIC.
EVERY OTHER YEAR BIG TENT IS A METAPHOR.
TODAY HERE IN RADCLIFFE YARD WE ARE LITERALLY
IN A BIG TENT WITH ALL OF YOU AND IT FEELS
WONDERFUL!
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
[APPLAUSE]
LET ME EXTEND A SPECIAL WELCOME TO OUR FORMER
RADCLIFFE LEADERS DEANS BARBARA GROSZ AND
MARY MAPLES DUNN.
DREW GILPIN FAUST IS HERE IN MANY CAPACITIES
AS THE FOUNDING DEAN OF THE RADCLIFFE INSTITUTE,
AS THE PRESIDENT OF HARVARD, AND AS LAST YEAR'S
RADCLIFFE MEDALIST.
OTHER MEDALISTS JOINING US HERE TODAY ARE
CHIEF JUSTICE MARGARET MARSHALL AND LEGAL
JOURNALIST LINDA GREENHOUSE.
WE CAN GIVE THEM ALL A HAND.
[APPLAUSE]
WE ALSO WELCOME MEMBERS OF RADCLIFFE'S DEAN'S
ADVISORY COUNCIL, SCHLESINGER LIBRARY COUNCIL,
AND HARVARD'S GOVERNING BOARDS, THE HARVARD'S
ALUMNI ASSOCIATION, AND PAST MEMBERS OF THE
RADCLIFFE ALUMNI ASSOCIATION AND BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
AND OF COURSE THE WARMEST OF WELCOMES TO RUTH
BADER GINSBURG, ASSOCIATE JUSTICE OF THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES.
[APPLAUSE]
I THINK YOU KNOW SHE WILL RECEIVE THE 2015
RADCLIFFE MEDAL TODAY.
AND WE ARE SO PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY HER
COLLEAGUE AND OUR SPECIAL GUEST ASSOCIATE
JUSTICE DAVID SOUTER.
[APPLAUSE]
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE RADCLIFFE COLLEGE
ALUMNI CELEBRATING MILESTONES THIS YEAR, INCLUDING
THE REUNION CLASSES OF 1945, 1950, 1955. MAYBE
WE'LL GIVE THEM ALL A HAND AT THE END. 1960.
1965. >> YEAH!
[LAUGHING]
>> 1970, AND 1975 AND ALL OTHERS CELEBRATING
REUNIONS ACROSS THE UNIVERSITY.
[APPLAUSE]
PLEASE ALSO JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING THE
EARLIEST CLASS IN ATTENDANCE TODAY, 1940.
[APPLAUSE]
RADCLIFFE COLLEGE WAS FOUNDED IN 1879 BY VISIONARIES
WHO DARED TO IMAGINE THAT WOMEN COULD AND
SHOULD UNDERTAKE SERIOUS SCHOLARLY INQUIRY
AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE WORLD OF IDEAS AND ACTION.
NEARLY A CENTURY LATER ANOTHER VISIONARY,
RADCLIFFE PRESIDENT MARY INGRAM BUNTING, ESTABLISHED
WHAT BECAME THE BUNTING INSTITUTE TO GIVE
EXCEPTIONAL WOMEN THE RESOURCES THEY NEEDED
TO REACH NEW PROFESSIONAL HEIGHTS.
TODAY THAT BOLD RADCLIFFE SPIRIT IS ALIVE
AND WELL.
SCHOLARS, SCIENTISTS, AND ARTISTS COME FROM
AROUND THE WORLD, ACROSS THE COUNTRY, OVER
THE RIVER FROM BOSTON, AND UP THE STREET FROM
HARVARD YARD TO BE PART OF THE RADCLIFFE INSTITUTE.
THESE WOMEN AND MEN PURSUE NEW KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
THE EXISTENCE OF EXTRA SOLAR PLANETS, THE
IMPACT OF RELIGIOUS COMMUNITIES ON MEDIEVAL
ARCHITECTURE,
THE ORIGINS OF HUMAN COOPERATION,
THE FORM AND FUNCTION OF THE BRAIN,
AND HOW TO PUT BIG DATA TO WORK.
THEY DELVE INTO THE PAPERS OF ORDINARY AND
EXTRAORDINARY WOMEN.
THEY WRITE AMBITIOUS NOVELS AND POETRY COLLECTIONS.
THEY IMPROVE PAIN MANAGEMENT FOR CHILDREN,
INVESTIGATE THE FUTURE OF NAVIGATION, AND
DEVELOP NEW APPROACHES TO ADDRESSING HUMANITARIAN
CRISES.
THEY WORK ALONE IN THE SANCTUARY OF AN OFFICE,
OR IN THE SCHLESINGER LIBRARY READING ROOM.
THEY WORK TOGETHER IN RESEARCH TEAMS AND WRITING
GROUPS.
THEY WORK WITH TALENTED AND CURIOUS HARVARD
UNDERGRADUATES THROUGH THE WONDERFUL RADCLIFFE
RESEARCH PARTNERS PROGRAM.
THEY PRODUCE NEW ART.
ALONG BRATTLE STREET, IN THE WALLACH GARDEN,
YOU CAN SEE A JUST-UNVEILED INSTALLATION BY
CHRISTINA LEE GEROS OF THE GRADUATE SCHOOL
OF DESIGN, WHO WON OUR STUDENT PUBLIC ART
COMPETITION. PLEASE RETURN AT NIGHT, IF YOU
CAN, TO SEE IT IN ITS FULL GLORY, BRILLIANTLY
LIT.
IN THE JOHNSON-KULUKUNDIS FAMILY GALLERY,
IN BYERLY HALL, YOU CAN SEE A TREE AS YOU’VE
NEVER SEEN ONE BEFORE, FROM BENEATH THE ROOTS.
AND THIS FALL, IN FRONT OF FAY HOUSE, WE’LL
BE INSTALLING AN INSPIRING NEW SCULPTURE BY
PHLYSSA KOSHLAND, CLASS OF 1971.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR, WE INVITE THE PUBLIC
TO LISTEN, LEARN, AND ENGAGE AT EVENTS THAT
ARE FREE AND INCREDIBLY DIVERSE.
JUST TO MENTION A FEW HIGH POINTS, THIS PAST
YEAR WE HEARD PROVOCATIVE REMARKS FROM
THE CREATOR OF THE GIANT SUGAR SPHINX IN BROOKLYN,
ARTIST KARA WALKER;
GEOLOGIST DAVID MONTGOMERY WHO EXPLORES THE
INTERSECTION OF SCIENCE AND RELIGION;
JAY SMOOTH, THE FOUNDER OF NEW YORK'S LONGEST
RUNNING HIP-HOP RADIO SHOW;
AND MAJOR GENERAL GINA M. GROSSO, THE DIRECTOR
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
FOR THE UNITED STATES AIR FORCE.
VIDEOS OF THESE PAST EVENTS, AND MANY OTHERS,
ARE AVAILABLE ONLINE.
BUT LET’S ALSO LOOK AHEAD.
I INVITE YOU TO RETURN FOR A CONFERENCE ABOUT
“CHARLOTTE PERKINS GILMAN AND THE ARCHIVES”
IN JUNE,
FOR AN EXHIBITION ABOUT SISTER CORITA KENT
IN AUGUST,
FOR A LECTURE BY SOUTH AFRICAN ACTIVIST DR.
MAMPHELA RAMPHELE IN SEPTEMBER,
AND FOR A SYMPOSIUM ABOUT THE FUTURE OF DNA
IN OCTOBER.
AND THAT’S ONLY A FRACTION OF WHAT’S IN
STORE IN THE YEAR AHEAD.
THE INSTITUTE'S FUTURE LOOKS BRIGHT NOT ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE IDEAS THAT ARE ILLUMINATED
HERE AT THE INSTITUTE, BUT ALSO BECAUSE THE
RADCLIFFE CAMPAIGN IS GOING VERY WELL.
I'M PLEASED TO TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE NOW REACHED
63% OF OUR $70 MILLION GOAL FOR A TOTAL OF
$44 MILLION.
SO FAR 6,000 HOUSEHOLDS HAVE GIVEN TO THE
RADCLIFFE CAMPAIGN.
AND I'LL LET YOU APPLAUD FOR THAT.
[APPLAUSE]
I REALLY AM PARTICULARLY PROUD OF THIS WIDESPREAD
PARTICIPATION.
AND I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR GENEROSITY.
WITH YOUR ONGOING SUPPORT, RADCLIFFE WILL
GROW EVEN STRONGER.
WHAT UNITES THE RADCLIFFE COMMUNITY IS A BELIEF
IN INQUIRY, IN EXPLORATION, AND IN INNOVATION.
THIS YEAR'S RADCLIFFE MEDALIST IS AN INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE LIFE AND WORK REPRESENT THE VALUES THAT
RADCLIFFE WAS FOUNDED UPON AND CONTINUES TO
UPHOLD TODAY.
RUTH BADER GINSBURG, ASSOCIATE JUSTICE OF
THE SUPREME COURT OF THE UNITED STATES HAS
CHALLENGED AND CHANGED EXPECTATIONS THROUGHOUT
HER LIFE.
MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW THAT SHE WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN BROOKLYN.
SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THAT HER CHILDHOOD
NAME WAS KICKY.
BUT FEW OF YOU MAY HAVE BEEN AWARE THAT SHE
WAS AN ACCOMPLISHED BATON TWIRLER IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
HER PEP SQUAD WAS CALLED THE GO GETTERS
AND THAT IS AN APT DESCRIPTION FOR A WOMAN
WHO GRADUATED FIRST IN HER CLASS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
FIRST IN HER CLASS AS AN UNDERGRADUATE AT
CORNELL AND FIRST IN HER CLASS AT COLUMBIA
LAW SCHOOL.
TALK ABOUT A GO GETTER.
[APPLAUSE]
AND JUSTICE GINSBURG IN HER COLLEGE YEARS
WAS MORE THAN STUDIOUS.
AT CORNELL SHE BECAME FAST FRIENDS WITH THE
OTHER WOMEN ON HER FLOOR.
THEY CALLED THEMSELVES KHLABIJ, AN ACRONYM
OF THEIR FIRST NAMES, STARTING WITH KICKY
AS THE "K."
THAT GROUP OF FRIENDS, SIX OF THEM NOW, HAVE
GOTTEN TOGETHER AS RECENTLY AS LAST YEAR.
WHILE NOT EVERYONE HAS AN ACRONYM FOR THEIR
ROOMMATES, THE TENT TODAY IS FILLED WITH PEOPLE
WHO STARTED FRIENDSHIPS IN COLLEGE HALLWAYS,
AND WHO CONTINUE TO STAY CONNECTED AND TO
BE IMPORTANT FOR ONE ANOTHER.
FOR THE WOMEN OF KHLABIJ, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPOSSIBLE TO PREDICT OUR WORLD IN WHICH THREE
WOMEN SERVE ON THE SUPREME COURT, A WOMAN
IS THE PRESIDENT OF HARVARD HARVARD HARVARD
UNIVERSITY, THE CEOS OF GENERAL MOTORS, IBM,
AND PEPSICO ARE WOMEN. A FEMALE FORMER SECRETARY
OF STATE IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
THE U.S. ARMED FORCES INCLUDES FOUR WOMEN
WHO HAVE ATTAINED FOUR STAR RANK.
AND HALF THE JUNIOR FACULTY HIRED THIS YEAR
AT HARVARD ARE WOMEN.
[APPLAUSE]
THE FIRST TIME GENDER PARITY HAS BEEN REACHED
ACROSS THE UNIVERSITY. THESE DEVELOPMENTS
MIGHT NOT HAVE EASILY BEEN FORESEEN. BUT MANY
OF YOU HERE TODAY IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND IN
DIFFERENT MOMENTS HELPED MAKE THEM HAPPEN.
AND WE ARE HERE TODAY TO HONOR HOW ONE PERSON,
OUR HONOREE, RUTH BADER GINSBURG, KNOCKED
ON CLOSED DOORS, OPENED THEM, AND THEN HELD
THEM OPEN FOR OTHERS.
WHEN JUSTICE GINSBURG GRADUATED FROM COLUMBIA
LAW SCHOOL, IT SEEMED UNLIKELY SHE WOULD GET
A CLERKSHIP, DESPITE HER CLASS RANK.
IF YOU WERE HERE THIS MORNING, YOU HEARD MICHAEL
KLARMAN TELL THIS STORY.
BUT I'M GOING TO TELL IT AGAIN BECAUSE IT'S
SUCH A GOOD ONE.
IT WASN'T JUST THAT SHE WAS A WOMAN, BUT SHE
WAS ALSO A MOTHER. WHO WOULD HIRE HER? PROFESSOR
GERRY GUNTHER, THEN ON THE COLUMBIA FACULTY,
RECOMMENDED JUSTIVE GINSBURG TO MANY, MANY
JUDGES. HE EVEN PROMISED THESE PERSPECTIVE
EMPLOYERS, THAT IF SHE DIDN'T WORK OUT HE
WOULD FIND A MALE LAWYER TO REPLACE HER.
WITH THAT PROMISE, JUSTICE GINSBURG WAS FINALLY
HIRED BY JUDGE EDMOND PALMIERI OF THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT.
AND HOW DID IT GO?
SO SUCCESSFULLY THAT THE NEXT CLERK HIRED
BY JUDGE PALMIERI WAS A WOMAN. JUSTICE GINSBURG
THEN OPENED OTHER DOORS IN OTHER WAYS.
AS THE COFOUNDER OF THE WOMEN'S RIGHT PROJECT
OF THE ACLU, SHE CHALLENGED INEQUALITY BY
CHANGING LAWS PIECE BY PIECE, CASE BY CASE,
WORKING WITH AND FOR EVERYDAY PEOPLE TO ADDRESS
EVERYDAY INJUSTICES.
SHE WON FIVE OF THE SIX CASES SHE BROUGHT
TO THE SUPREME COURT.
HER VICTORIES LED TO IMPORTANT IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE LIVES OF WOMEN AND MEN AND THEIR FAMILIES.
SUCH AS SECURING SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS
FOR FATHERS, OBTAINING SPOUSAL BENEFITS FOR
WOMEN IN THE MILITARY, AND ELIMINATING GENDER
BASED JURY SERVICE EXEMPTIONS IN PART BY ARGUING
THAT OPTIONAL JURY DUTY FOR WOMEN TREATS WOMEN'S
SERVICE ON JURIES AS LESS VALUABLE THAN MEN'S
AND THREATENS WOMEN'S RIGHT TO TRIAL BY A
JURY OF THEIR PEERS.
BEGINNING IN 1980, RUTH BADER GINSBURG SERVED
ON THE U.S. COURT OF APPEALS FOR THE DISTRICT
COLUMBIA.
SOME FEARED THAT SHE, A PASSIONATE ADVOCATE
FOR THE COURTS WOULD INTENSIFY A INTENSIFY
WHAT WAS ALREADY CONSIDERED A HIGHLY POLARIZED
COURT. AGAIN SHE DEIFED EXPECTATIONS.
SHE WAS PARTIAL TO IMPARTIALITY.
SHE SOUGHT CLARITY AND CONSISTENCY IN THE
IMPORTANT WORK OF THE APPEALS COURT.
AS A JUDGE, SHE DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT
NOT TO GENERATING HEAT, BUT TO SHEDDING LIGHT.
WHEN PRESIDENT CLINTON APPOINTED RUTH BADER
GINSBURG TO THE SUPREME COURT IN 1993, SHE
JOINED SANDRA DAY O'CONNOR AS ONLY THE SECOND
WOMAN ON THE COURT IN ITS HISTORY.
IT WAS AN INSTITUTION SO MALE THAT A POPULAR
HISTORY OF THE COURT WAS ENTITLED THE BRETHREN.
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN JUDGES,
AN ORGANIZATION WHOSE PAPERS WE'RE GRATEFUL
TO HAVE IN THE RADCLIFFE SCHLESINGER LIBRARY,
AND WHOSE MEMBERSHIP IS VERY WELL REPRESENTED
HERE TODAY, BRILLIANTLY UNDERSCORED THE POINT
BY GIVING JUSTICE O'CONNOR A T SHIRT THAT
SAID I'M SANDRA, NOT RUTH. AND JUSTICE GINSBURG
GETS MADE, I'M RUTH NOT SANDRA.
JUSTICE GINSBURG WAS HARDLY INTIMIDATED.
IF SHE WAS, NO ONE WHO OBSERVED HER ASKING
QUESTIONS FROM THE BENCH, ENGAGING COLLEAGUES
OR ISSUING QUESTIONS COULD DETECT IT.
A SELECTION OF MAJORITY OPINIONS SHE WROTE
INCLUDES ELIMINATING THE BAN ON WOMEN AT THE
VIRGINIA MILITARY INSTITUTE. ENABLING A PARENT
TO TRY TO REGAIN CUSTODY OF HER CHILDREN DESPITE
HER INABILITY TO PAY COURT FEES.
STRENGTHENING THE POWER OF THE FEDERAL EPA
TO ENFORCE THE CLEAN AIR ACT.
DEFENDING THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
DISABILITIES TO LIVE IN COMMUNITY SETTINGS
AND NOT BE INSTITUTIONALIZED.
UPHOLDING THE RIGHT OF A DEATH PENALTY DEFENDANT
TO TURN TO THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
AS A COURT OF LAST RESORT, AND SHIELDING CITIZENS
FROM UNREASONABLE SEARCH AND SEIZURE.
A DOZEN YEARS AGO JUSTICE GINSBURG WAS PART
OF THE MAJORITY OPINION ALLOWING RACE TO BE
A PART OF FACTOR IN LAW SCHOOL ADMISSIONS
IN RECOGNITION THAT DISCRIMINATION LIVES ON
IN AMERICA DESPITE OUR HOPES AND IDEALS TO
THE CONTARY.
WHILE SOME IN THE MAJORITY FORECAST THAT RACE
BASED CONSIDERATIONS WOULD SURELY NOT BE RELEVANT
25 YEARS AFTER THE DECISION, JUSTICES GINSBURG
AND BREYER TOOK A LESS SANGUINED VIEW.
THESE DAYS THEIR DOUBTS SEEM ALL TOO PRESCIENT.
EVEN WHEN JUSTICE GINSBURG WAS NOT IN THE
MAJORITY, SHE SHAPES THE WAY WE LIVE AND WORK.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE LILLY LEDBETTER EQUAL
PAY CASE, THE MAJORITY DECISION AND PRACTICE
ALLOWED PAY DISCRIMINATION TO CONTINUE INDEFINITELY.
WHEN JUSTICE GINSBURG DELIVERED HER DISSENT,
SHE CHARGED CONGRESS WITH CORRECTING HER COLLEAGUE'S
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW.
WITHIN 18 MONTHS, WHICH IS RECORD SPEED IN
OUR SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT, CONGRESS PASSED
THE LLILY LEDBETTER FAIR PAY ACT, AND IT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW BY PRESIDENT OBAMA.
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTICE GINSBURG'S ACCESSIBLE, INCISIVE DECISIONS
AND POWERFUL DISSENTS HAVE CHALLENGED ASSUMPTIONS
AND CHANGED ACTIONS.
WHAT ANIMATES ALL HER OPINIONS IS A QUALIFIED
COMMITMENT TO FAIRNESS, AND A WILLINGNESS
TO GRAPPLE WITH WHAT THE FOUNDER'S VISION
OF EQUALITY MEANS TODAY.
IN ADDITION TO SHAPING LAW, PUBLIC POLICY,
AND PUBLIC OPINION, OUR HONOREE IS IN FULL
BLOOM AS A CULTURAL ICON.
SHE, OR RATHER A DIVA WHO WILL BE PERFORMING
AS JUSTICE GINSBURG, WILL SOON STAR IN THE
OPERA SCALIA/GINSBURG RECENTLY WRITTEN BY
DEREK WANG, HARVARD CLASS OF 2006. IT'S NOT
ONLY THE FIRST OPERA ABOUT THE HIGHEST COURT
IN OUR LAND, BUT IT ALSO HAS MORE FOOTNOTES
THAN ANY OTHER LIBRETTO.
IN FACT, ONE ARIA, SUNG BY JUSTICE GINSBURG,
OR THE DIVA, IS ANNOTATED WITH 50 FOOTNOTES.
NOW THAT'S A LOT.
BUT GIVEN THAT THE ARIA IS SUNG TO JUSTICE
SCALIA AND IT'S CALLED "YOU SIR ARE WRONG
HERE" THAT IS PERHAPS FEWER FOOTNOTES THAN
ONE MIGHT EXPECT.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU NEED NOT BE AN OPERA CONNOISSEUR TO APPRECIATE
JUSTICE GINSBURG'S PLACE IN OUR CULTURE TODAY.
SHE IS A POP ICON.
WHILE STAYING ON THE BENCH, SHE HAS ALSO MOVED
ONTO FACEBOOK, TUMBLER, INSTAGRAM, T SHIRTS,
MUGS, YOU NAME IT, EVEN HALLOWEEN.
KIDS ALL ACROSS AMERICA, NOT JUST IN CAMBRIDGE,
MASSACHUSETTS AND WASHINGTON, D.C. DRESSED
AS JUSTICE GINSBURG FOR TRICK OR TREATING.
THE MOST POPULAR IMAGE ONLINE WAS OF A BABY
WITH THE EARRINGS, THE GLASSES, THE ROBE,
AND A CERTAIN STEELY LOOK.
I DON'T KNOW HOW OUR HONOREE FEELS ABOUT THIS
LEVEL OF FAME.
BUT I HOPE SHE TAKES ENORMOUS PLEASURE AS
WE ALL SHOULD IN THE FACT THAT THE BABY WHO
WON THIS HALLOWEEN CONTEST DRESSED AS RUTH
BADER GINSBURG WAS A BOY.
[APPLAUSE]
THAT LIKE SO MANY OF RUTH BADER GINSBURG'S
EXTRAORDINARY ACCOMPLISHMENTS IS A SIGN OF
THE PROGRESS SHE HAS ACHIEVED FOR WOMEN, FOR
MEN, AND FOR THE FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE OF
MAKING EQUITY AND FAIRNESS A REALITY FOR ALL.
WE WILL HEAR FROM JUSTICE GINSBURG SHORTLY
WHEN SHE ENGAGES IN CONVERSATION WITH KATHLEEN
SULLIVAN, A BRILLIANT LITIGATOR AND CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLAR WHO HAS BEEN ON THE FACULTIES OF HARVARD
LAW SCHOOL AND STANFORD LAW SCHOOL, WHERE
SHE WAS ALSO DEAN.
KATHLEEN IS A PARTNER IN THE FIRM THAT SOME
REFER TO AS QUINN EMMANUEL BUT WE PREFER TO
CALL IT BY ITS FULL NAME: QUINN EMMANUEL URQUHART
& SULLIVAN.
AND WE ARE DELIGHTED AND GRATEFUL TO HAVE
KATHLEEN SULLIVAN JOIN US TODAY.
BUT FIRST JOIN ME IN WELCOMING JUSTICE DAVID
SOUTER TO THE PODIUM.
[APPLAUSE]
HE SERVED ON THE SUPREME COURT FROM 1990 TO
2009, INCLUDING MORE THAN 15 YEARS ALONGSIDE
JUSTICE GINSBURG.
WHEN WE ASKED JUSTICE SOUTER TO SPEAK ABOUT
HIS PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL REGARD FOR JUSTICE
GINSBURG HE SAID WE WERE HONORING HIM, AND
I QUOTE, MUNIFICENTLY.
WITH A VOCABULARY LIKE THAT, DO I EVEN NEED
TO SAY HE WAS HARVARD GRADUATE? OF THE COLLEGE
AND ALSO A GRADUATE OF HARVARD LAW SCHOOL.
JUSTICE SOUTER HONORS US ALL AND JUSTICE GINSBURG
MUNIFICENTLY BY JOINING US HERE TODAY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> DAVID SOUTER: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DEAN COHEN AND MEMBERS OF THE HIERARCHY TODAY,
JUSTICE GINSBURG, AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
ACTUALLY I WASN'T SURE IF I WAS GOING TO BE
SAYING GENTLEMEN, BUT AS I LOOK OUT OVER THE
AUDIENCE, I REALIZE THAT THIS IDEA OF RUTH'S
OF GENDER EQUALITY SEEMS TO HAVE CAUGHT ON
HERE.
IT'S WONDERFUL.
AS THE DEAN SUGGESTED, I'M RATHER A TRANSITIONAL
FIGURE HERE TODAY.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO TRY, I WAS NOT AUTHORIZED
TO TRY TO RECAP EITHER JUSTICE GINSBURG'S
LITIGATING EXPERIENCE OR THE SUBSTANCE OF
HER DECISIONS.
I WAS ASKED AT LEAST AS BEST I COULD FIGURE
IT OUT TO BASICALLY PROVIDE SOME PERSONAL
ATMOSPHERE. THAT AT LEAST WOULD BE CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT YOU'VE BEEN HEARING AND PROBABLY
WILL HEAR A BIT MORE OF BEFORE THE AFTERNOON
IS OVER.
AND IN TRYING TO FIND SOME WAY TO SUM UP SOME
OF THE ATMOSPHERICS THAT I WANT TO GET INTO,
I THOUGHT OF A PERFECT QUOTATION FROM LEARNED
HAND.
AND THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE NOT JUDGES AND LAWYERS,
I ASSUME THERE ARE SOME, NEED TO KNOW ONLY
THAT LEARNED HAND WAS ONE OF THE MOST IMMINENT
JUDGES IN THE ANGLO AMERICAN TRADITION.
HE WAS ON THE UNITED STATES COURT OF APPEALS
FOR THE SECOND CICUIT WHICH BASED IN NEW YORK.
AND ONE THING LEAS TO ANOTHER. ONCE I THOUGHT
OF THE HAND QUOTE THAT I WANTED TO WORK IN
MY REMARKS, I STARTED THINKING ABOUT OTHER
THINKS BY AND ABOUT LEARNED HAND.
I'M GOING TO START WITH A STORY THAT HE TOLD
ABOUT HIMSELF.
HE TOLD IT IN MORE THAN ONE PLACE, AND THERE
ARE DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF IT.
BUT THIS IS THE BASIC STORY.
IT'S A STORY OF HIS FANTASY OF HIS FIRST DAY
IN HEAVEN.
AND IN THE MORNING THERE IS, THERE IS A BASEBALL
GAME.
AND IT TURNS OUT THAT IT'S THE BOTTOM OF THE
NINTH AND HAND'S TEAM HAS NOT HAD A RUN.
THE OPPOSING TEAM HAS HAD THREE.
BUT THE BASES ARE LOADED AND HAND IS UP AT
BAT AND HE HITS A HOMER AND ALL FOUR COME
IN AND HE IS IDOLIZED AS THE HERO OF THE MORNING.
AND AFTER LUNCH THAT DAY THERE IS A FOOTBALL
GAME.
AND AS HAND WOULD TELL THE STORY, IT WAS THE
FOURTH QUARTER WITH THREE MINUTES LEFT TO
PLAY AND THE GAME WAS SCORELESS.
AND SOMEHOW BACK ON ABOUT THE 30 YARD LINE
HAND GOT THE BALL AND HE MIR MIRACULOUSLY
MADE HIS WAY DOWN ACCROSS THE GOAL LINE AND
OF COURSE THE COMPANY OF HEAVEN ERUPTED IN
RAPTURE IN WHAT HE HAD DONE.
AND THAT EVENING, THE CROWNING EVENT OF THE
DAY WAS A FORMAL DINNER FOR THE GREAT PHILOSOPHICAL
INTELLECTS OF ALL TIME.
PLATO WAS THERE.
ARISTOTLE WAS THERE.
AQUINAS, LOCKE, HUME, BERKELEY, AND THE SPEAKER
FOR THE EVENING WAS VOLTAIRE.
AND SO THE TIME CAME AND VOLTAIRE GOT UP AND
BEGAN HIS REMARKS.
BUT AS HE SPOKE, THOUGH, THE GREAT THINKERS
THERE BEGAN TO LOOK AROUND A LITTLE BIT, AND
THEY NOTICED THAT THEIR NEWEST MEMBER HAND
WAS THERE.
AND THE AUDIENCE BEGAN TO BECOME A LITTLE
BIT RESTIVE.
AND AFTER A WHILE MURMURING WAS HEARD.
AND FINALY THE MURMURING GAVE WAY TO SORT
OF OUT SPOKEN COMMENT AND SOMEBODY YELLED
SAID SHUT UP VOLTAIRE.
ANOTHER PERSON GOT UP AND SAID SIT DOWN VOLTAIRE!
WE WANT TO HEAR FROM HAND.
WELL, I REALIZE THAT AS THE MAN WHO IS STANDING
BETWEEN YOU AND HEARING JUSTICE GINSBURG...
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
I
KNOW THE SPOT THAT VOLTAIRE WAS IN.
BUT I'M GOING TO, I'M GOING TO RELY ON YOUR
INDULGENCE FOR A FEW MINUTES TO HELP ME GET
OUT OF THE SPOT THAT I'M IN BY LETTING ME,
LETTING ME TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
SORT OF THE DRIVE THAT LIES BEHIND THE DRIVE
AND THE PERSONALITY THAT LIES BEHIND JUSTICE
GINSBURG'S EXTRAORDINARY ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
WHAT I REALLY I GUESS AM GOING TO DO IS SORT
OF GIVE YOU SOME TIPS FOR THINGS TO LOOK FOR
AND LISTEN FOR BEHIND WHAT SHE IS SAYING THIS
AFTERNOON.
AND MY FIRST TIP FOR YOU IS DON'T BE FOOLED
BY THE FORMALITIES OF PROFESSIONAL DISCOURSE
THAT WILL PROBABLY GO ON BETWIXT HER AND KATHLEEN
SULLIVAN.
DON'T BE FOOLED BECAUSE ALONG WITH EXTRAORDINARY
AND UNFAILING NATURAL COURTESY, JUSTICE GINSBURG
SEEMS TO FIND IT COMPATIBLE TO HAVE AN ENORMOUS
STORE OF THE GUMPTION TO SPEAK UP AND TO SPEAK
OUT.
YOU WOULD EXPECT THIS SIMPLY FROM WHAT YOU
ALREADY KNOW ABOUT HER.
AND YOU WOULD CERTAINLY EXPECT IT THE MORE
AFTER YOU HEAR FROM HER.
BUT I'M JUST GOING TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
STORIES THAT ILLUSTRATE THAT FACT TO SET IT
IN YOUR MIND.
AND THE FIRST OF THEM TAKES ME BACK TO THE
VERY FIRST MORNING THAT I SAT ON THE BENCH
OF THE SUPREME COURT WITH JUSTICE GINSBURG
BACK IN OCTOBER OF 1993. BECAUSE SHE WAS THE
NEWEST JUSTICE SHE WAS SITTING TO MY LEFT
ON THE BENCH.
AND TO MY RIGHT WAS HER FRIEND AND MY FRIEND
JUSTICE SCALIA.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT BOTH JUSTICE SCALIA
AND I TEND TO BE ACTIVE QUESTIONERS OF THE
LAWYERS WHO ARE ARGUING BEFORE US.
WE WANT TO GET THE ARGUMENTS TO THE ISSUES
THAT ARE TROUBLING US ABOUT WHICH WE HAVE
QUESTIONS THAT GO TO THE CASE OF THE LAWYER
WHO WAS ARGUING.
AND WE TRY TO GET RIGHT TO IT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THAT MORNING NEITHER
JUSTICE SCALIA NOR I WAS EXPECTING ANY SERIOUS
COMPETITION FROM THE NEWCOMER IN INTERROGATING
THE LAWYERS.
BUT WE WERE IN FOR A BIG SURPRISE.
[LAUGHTER]
JUSTICE GINSBURG WAS OFF THE MARK WITH THE
FIRST QUESTION BEFORE JUSTICE SCALIA AND I
HAD OUR MOUTHS OPEN.
AND NOT ONLY THAT, BUT SHE KEPT IT UP!
AND EVERY TIME HE OR I WOULD GET READY TO
ASK A QUESTION, THERE WOULD BE ANOTHER ONE
FROM THE JUNIOR MEMBER OF THE COURT.
AND FINALLY AFTER A COUPLE OF MINUTES OF FRUSTRATED
SILENCE JUSTICE SCALIA LEANED OVER TO ME AND
WHISPERED AND HE SAID YOU AND I MAY HAVE ASKED
OUR LAST QUESTIONS IN THIS COURTROOM.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT HE AND I BECAME SOMEWHAT
MORE NIMBLE OVER THE YEARS AND WE WERE ABLE
TO GET IN A FEW OF OUR OWN.
AND I'LL TELL YOU, I'LL TELL YOU ANOTHER STORY
THAT OF SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED TO
ME VERY OFTEN.
BUT IT HAS HAPPENED.
JUSTICE GINSBURG AND I, SO FAR AS STATISTICS
GO, IN OUR YEARS TOGETHER, TENDED TO COME
OUT WITH A VERY HIGH DEGREE OF FREQUENT AGREEMENT.
BUT NOT ALWAYS.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT IF YOU ARE DISSENTING
FROM AN OPINION OF JUSTICE GINSBURG'S, OR
SHE IS DISSENTING FROM AN OPINION OF YOURS,
THE ONLY THING FOR YOU TO DO IS CANCEL ALL
OTHER PLANS FOR THE NEAR FUTURE.
BECAUSE YOU ARE GOING TO BE AT IT FOR A LONG
TIME.
JUSTICE GINSBURG TO ADAPT A PHRASE THAT HAS
BECOME COMMON, JUSTICE GINSBURG IS A TIGER
JUSTICE.
THOSE TWO, THOSE TWO QUALITIES OF SORT OF
INTELLECTUAL INITIATIVE AND BOTH INTELLECTUAL
AND EMOTIONAL STAMINA ARE THE QUALITIES THAT
MADE ME THINK OF THAT QUOTATION FROM LEARNED
HAND THAT I ELUDED TO BEFORE
THEY ARE THE QUALITIES THAT GO INTO THE MAKING
OF A GREAT JUSTICE, AND A GREAT JUSTICE IS
WHAT JUSTICE GINSBURG IS.
AND LEARNED HAND WAS LECTURING ONCE A GOOD
MANY YEARS AGO ONCE OVER AT THE LAW SCHOOL.
AND HE WAS DESCRIBING WHY IT WAS THAT HE STILL
REVERED THE PROFESSORS WHO HAD TAUGHT HIM
LAW THERE.
AND THIS IS THE PHRASE HE USED TO SUM UP.
IN THE UNIVERSE OF TRUTH, THEY LIVED BY THE
SWORD.
WELL, SO DOES JUSTICE GINSBURG.
AND IN ADDITION TO DOING THAT, THERE IS A
GRACE THAT ALSO MUST BE NOTED.
YOU'RE GOING TO LIKE HER.
[LAUGHTER]
WHEN I WAS, WHEN I WAS THINKING OF WHAT I
MIGHT SAY THIS AFTERNOON I WENT TO MY FILE
CABINET AND I PULLED OUT THE NOTES THAT I
HAD MADE OF THE ARGUMENTS AND OUR DISCUSSIONS
OF THE CASES THAT FIRST WEEK THAT SHE SAT
WITH US BACK IN 1993. AND MY NOTES FOR THE
LATTER PART OF THE WEEK INCLUDED THIS STATEMENT.
AND I QUOTE MYSELF.
I CAN'T RESERVE CAUTION IN MY DELIGHT WITH
RUTH.
[APPLAUSE]
GET YOURSELVES READY TO FEEL THE SAME WAY.
LUNCH IS BEHIND US.
AND WE ARE NOW GOING TO HAVE A FEAST IN THE
COMPANY OF JUSTICE GINSBURG AND KATHLEEN SULLIVAN.
IT'S WHAT LEARNED HAND MIGHT HAVE CALLED A
DOUBLE HEADER.
AND I HAVE, I HAVE KNOWN MISS SULLIVAN BOTH
IN HER CAPACITY AS A LECTURER, AND IN HER
CAPACITY AS A LAW SCHOOL DEAN.
I KNOW HER ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS A PROFESSOR.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT SHE HONORS ALL OF
US BY JOINING WITH US TO HELP US HONOR RUTH
GINSBURG TODAY.
AND AS I MAKE WAY FOR THE TWO OF THEM, LET
ME JUST ASK YOU TO REMEMBER ONE THING.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE HEARING THEM FOR MAYBE
HALF AN HOUR.
I HAVE KNOWN AND LISTENED TO EACH OF THEM
FOR A GOOD MANY YEARS.
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO FORGET THEM.
AND YOU'RE ALWAYS GOING TO ENVY ME.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, AND DEAN COHEN, AND JUSTICE
SOUTER, JUSTICE GINSBURG, MARVELOUS AND DISTINGUISHED
ALUMNAE OF RADCLIFFE, MANY CLASSES STONG,
IT IS SUCH A DEEP HONOR AND PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
FOR ME TO CONDUCT THIS CONVERSATION WITH JUSTICE
GINSBURG.
YOU'VE HEARD A GREAT DEAL ABOUT HER LIFE TODAY
AT HARVARD LAW SCHOOL, A STONE'S THROW AWAY
FROM HERE, TO HER CAREER AS A LAWYER, TO HER
TIME AS TIGER JUSTICE, TO HER BEING THE STAR
OF AN OPERA, SCALIA/GINSBERG, AND KNOWN IN
RAP CIRCLES AS NOTORIOUS RBG.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE US BACK TO THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN ALLUDED TO IN THIS MORNING'S
MARVELOUS PANEL, YOUR LIFE AS A LAWYER.
IT'S NO SECRET TO THOSE WHO PRACTICE BEFORE
THE SUPREME COURT, AND FOLLOW THE SUPREME
COURT, THAT JUSTICE GINSBURG IS NOT JUST A
JUDGE'S JUDGE, OR A JUSTICE'S JUSTICE, SHE
IS A LAWYER'S LAWYER,
THE ONE WHO WRITES PERHAPS THE MOST OF THE
CIVIL PROCEDURE CASES.
AND WHO FORGED A CAREER AS A BRILLIANT LITIGATOR
FOR THE WOMEN'S RIGHTS PROJECT OF THE ACLU
BACK IN THE EARLY '70S. AND AT A TIME WHEN
THERE WAS NO EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT,
NO UPDATE TO THE WORDS OF THE CONSTITUTION
IN THE 14TH AMENDMENT IN 1868 THAT SAID NO
STATE SHOULD DEPRIVE ANY PERSON OF EQUAL PROTECTION
OF THE LAWS.
BUT NO CLEAR EXTENSION OF THAT PRINCIPLE,
TO THE PRINCIPLE OF SEX EQUALITY.
JUSTICE GINSBURG MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE FORGED
THAT DEVELOPMENT IN THE LAW.
JUSTICE GINSBURG, I WONDER IF WE COULD START
BY GOING BACK TO THE '70S, AND HAVE YOU TALK
ABOUT THE TURNING POINT CASES, THE CASE OF
REED V. REED. THAT YOU WORKED ON, OR FRONTIERO
V. RICHARDSON.
CAN YOU TAKE US BACK AND TELL US ABOUT THOSE
CASES?
>> RUTH BADER GINSBURG: KATHLEEN, BEFORE I
DO THAT LET ME SAY THAT I DON'T THINK THERE'S
BEEN A HIGHER NOTE THAN THERE WAS THIS MORNING
AND WITH MY DEAR COLLEAGUE JUSTICE SOUTER.
I LOVED IT ALL AND I HOPE YOU ENJOYED IT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ADD A P.S. TO SOMETHING
MY COLLEAGUE SAID.
IN THE YEARS WE SERVED TOGETHER, JUSTICE SOUTER
AND I VOTED ALIKE MORE THAN ANY TWO OTHER
JUSTICES, EVEN MORE THAN JUSTICE SCALIA AND
JUSTICE THOMAS.
I MISS HIM, BUT I OCCUPY THE CHAMBERS THAT
WERE HIS WHEN HE WAS ON THE COURT.
THEY LOOK A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
BUT I THINK OF HIM WITH GREAT APPRECIATION
FOR WHAT A WONDERFUL COLLEAGUE HE WAS.
ANYWAY, SALLY REED.
SALLY REED IS A WOMAN FROM BOISE, IDAHO AND
SHE HAS HAD A TRAGIC OCCURRENCE IN HER LIFE.
SALLY WAS CHILDLESS FOR YEARS AND THEN SHE
AND HER HUSBAND ADOPTED A BABY BOY AND THEN
THEY HAD A FALLING OUT SO THEY SEPARATED.
AND THE YOUNG BOY WAS GIVEN TO SALLY AS PRIMARY
CUSTODIAN BECAUSE THE CHILD WAS WHAT THE LAW
CALLED OF TENDER YEARS.
WHEN THE BOY REACHED HIS TEENS, FATHER APPLIED
FOR CUSTODY.
HIS ARGUMENT WAS NOW THE BOY NEEDS TO BE PREPARED
FOR A MAN'S WORLD.
THE JUDGE SAID YES.
SALLY OPPOSED IT.
SHE THOUGHT THE FATHER WOULD NOT BE A GOOD
INFLUENCE ON THE BOY.
AND SADLY SHE PROVED TO BE RIGHT.
ONE DAY THE BOY WAS SORELY DEPRESSED AND HE
TOOK OUT ONE OF HIS FATHER'S MANY GUNS AND
HE COMMITTED SUICIDE.
SO SALLY WANTED TO BE APPOINTED ADMINISTRATOR
OF HIS ESTATE.
THE PROBATE COURT JUDGE TOLD HER I'M SORRY
SALLY, BUT THE LAW IS CLEAR.
THE IDAHO PROBATE CODE SAYS AS BETWEEN PEOPLE
EQUALLY ENTITLED TO ADMINISTER'S A DESCENDANTS
ESTATE, MALES MUST BE PREFERRED TO FEMALES.
IT WAS THE PERFECT STATUTE TO ATTACK AS DISCRIMINATING
ARBITRARILY AGAINST A WOMAN.
BUT WHAT SALLY REID'S CASE BROUGHT HOME TO
ME WAS THAT THIS IS A WOMAN WHO WAS HARDLY
SOPHISTICATED.
SHE PROBABLY DIDN'T CALL HERSELF A FEMINIST.
SHE PROBABLY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE WORD
MEANT.
BUT SHE THOUGHT SHE SUFFERED AN INJUSTICE
AND THAT THE LEGAL SYSTEM COULD MAKE IT RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY COUNTRIES THAT WOULD
BE SO.
SO SALLY WENT THROUGH THREE LEVELS OF THE
IDAHO COURTS.
SHE LOST THE FIRST TIME, WON THE SECOND TIME,
AND LOST THE THIRD TIME.
THE SUPREME COURT HEARD HER CASE AND FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THE HISTORY OF THAT COURT THEY
SAID THAT A GENDER CLASSIFICATION VIOLATED
THE PRINCIPLE OF THE EQUAL PROTECTION OF THE
LAWS.
>> KATHLEEN SULLIVAN: AND THAT WAS QUITE REMARKABLE,
BECAUSE THE EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT, WHICH
HAD BEEN ENACTED IN CONGRESS NUMEROUS TIMES,
BUT NEVER RATIFIED BY THE STATES WAS NOT YET
ENFORCED.
SO YOU HAD TO MAKE NEW LAW WITH THE EXISTING
LANGUAGE OF THE CONSTITUTION.
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
HOW DID YOU CONVINCE THEM THAT THE LAW IN
IDAHO WAS IRRATIONAL TO DISCRIMINATE BETWEEN
MEN AND WOMEN.
>> RUTH BADER GINSBURG: WE WENT THROUGH EVERY
EQUAL PROTECTION DECISION, THERE WEREN'T THAT
MANY OUTSIDE OF THE RACE AREA
AND PICKED UP THE BEST LANGUAGE THAT WE COULD
FIND.
AND IT WAS JUST THE LIFE STORY OF THIS WOMAN
AND THE ARBITRARINESS OF THE LAW.
NOW THE LAW, IT WAS UNDERSTANDABLE BECAUSE
IT WAS COPIED BY IDAHO FROM CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS MIDDLE 19TH CENTURY LAW.
THE THINKING WAS THAT WOMEN ONCE THEY MARRIED
LOSE THEIR RIGHT TO CONTRACT IN THEIR OWN
NAME, SUE AND BE SUED IN THEIR OWN NAMES,
HOLD PROPERTY.
SO ALL THINGS CONSIDERED, IF YOU HAD A CHOICE
BETWEEN A MAN WHO WAS COMPETENT AND A WOMAN
WHO WAS UNDER THESE LAW IMPOSED DISABILITIES,
YOU WOULD PREFER THE MAN.
>> KATHLEEN SULLIVAN: NOW A NUMBER OF THE
LAWS THAT YOU CHALLENGED DURING THIS PIVOTAL
PERIOD WITH THE ACLU WOMEN'S RIGHTS PROJECT
WERE ACTUALLY LAWS THAT GAVE A PARENT PRIVILEGES
TO WOMEN OVER MEN.
LAWS THAT ASSUMED THAT MILITARY WIVES WERE
DEPENDENT ON THEIR SERVICE MEMBER'S, HUSBAND'S
INCOME.
OR SOCIAL SECURITY CLASSIFICATIONS THAT ASSUMED
THAT WIVES WERE DEPENDENT ON HUSBANDS, BUT
HUSBANDS WOULD HAVE TO PROVE DEPENDENCY TO
GET BENEFITS EARNED BY THEIR WIVES.
YOU MIGHT SAY THEY WERE LAWS THAT WERE SEX
DISCRIMINATION, BUT NOMINALLY IN FAVOR OF
WOMEN.
AND YET YOU TOOK THOSE CASES ON, AS WELL.
IN CASES LIKE FRONTIERO, AND LATER IN CASE
LIKE WIESENFELD.
CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY YOU
CHALLENGED ON BEHALF OF MEN SOME OF THESE
APPARENT PRIVILEGES FOR LADIES?
>> RUTH BADER GINSBURG: THE OBJECT WAS TO
GET AT THE STEREOTYPE THAT HELD WOMEN BACK
FROM DOING WHATEVER THEIR TALENT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO DO.
THE NOTION WAS THERE WERE SEPARATE SPHERES
FOR THE SEXES.
MEN WERE THE DOERS IN THE WORLD OF COMMERCE.
AND WOMEN WERE THE STAY AT HOME TYPES WHO
LOOKED AFTER THE HEARTH AND THE CHILDREN.
AND WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WAS
TO GET RID OF ALL LAWS BASED ON THAT STEREOTYPE
SO PEOPLE, WOMEN AS WELL AS MEN COULD BE IN
THE WORDS OF A SONG POPULAR IN THE EARLY '70s,
FREE TO BE YOU AND ME.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN WIESENFELD'S CASE WAS A TRAGIC CIRCUMSTANCE.
HE WAS MARRIED TO A HIGH SCHOOL MATH TEACHER.
THEIR DIVISION AT HOME HE WAS THE PRINCIPLE
HOME BODY, AND SHE WAS THE PRINCIPLE EARNER.
SHE HAD A HEALTHY PREGNANCY, SHE WAS TEACHING
INTO HER 9TH MONTH.
SHE WENT TO THE HOSPITAL TO GIVE BIRTH.
THE DOCTOR CAME OUT AND TOLD STEPHEN YOU HAVE
A HEALTHY BABY BOY, BUT YOUR WIFE DIED OF
AN EMBOLISM.
SO STEPHEN VOWED THAT HE WOULD BE THE CARE
GIVING PARENT.
HE WOULD NOT WORK FULL TIME UNTIL HIS CHILD
WAS IN SCHOOL FULL TIME.
AND HE COULD MANAGE THAT, HE THOUGHT, BY WHAT
WERE CALLED CHILD AND CARE SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS.
HE COULD EARN UP TO THE EARNINGS LIMIT, WHAT
HE EARNED, PLUS THE SOCIAL SECURITY.
HE COULD MANAGE TO CARE FOR HIS CHILD AND
HIMSELF.
SO HE WENT TO THE SOCIAL SECURITY OFFICE TO
ASK FOR THESE CHILD IN CARE BENEFITS AND WAS
TOLD THIS IS A STATUTE, YOU SEE, IT SAYS MOTHER'S
BENEFITS.
THEY WEREN'T AVAILABLE TO THE FATHER.
AND HOW THE CASE BEGAN, STEPHEN WROTE A LETTER
TO THE EDITOR OF HIS LOCAL NEWSPAPER IN EDISON,
NEW JERSEY.
THE LETTER SAID I HAVE BEEN HEARING A LOT
ABOUT WOMEN'S LIB.
LET ME TELL YOU MY STORY.
THE TAGLINE AFTER HE SAID I DON'T GET THESE
BENEFITS AS A PARENT.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
DOES GLORIA STEINEM KNOW ABOUT THIS?
[LAUGHTER]
WELL SOMEONE WHO WAS ON THE SPANISH FACULTY
AT RUTGERS UNIVERSITY, AND A FRIEND, CALLED
ME AND SAID THIS ISN'T RIGHT, IS IT?
SO I SUGGESTED THAT STEPHEN WIESENFELD CALL
THE NEW JERSEY AFFILIATE OF THE ACLU.
AND WE TOOK THAT CASE FROM THE DISTRICT COURT
TO THE SUPREME COURT.
I'M VERY PROUD OF THIS BECAUSE WE GOT THE
DECISION FROM THE SUPREME COURT BEFORE JASON,
THE BABY, TURNED THREE.
AND THAT'S A RECORD, REALLY A RECORD!
[APPLAUSE]
ANYWAY, IT WAS A UNANIMOUS JUDGMENT, BUT THEY
DIVIDED THREE WAYS ON WHO WAS THE VICTIM OF
THE DISCRIMINATION.
THE MAJORITY SAID OF COURSE IT'S THE WAGE
EARNING WOMAN.
SHE PAYS THE SAME SOCIAL SECURITY TAXES AS
A MAN PAYS, BUT THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T GIVE
HER FAMILY THE SAME PROTECTION IT WOULD GIVE
TO A MAN'S FAMILY.
AND THEN IT WAS DISCRIMINATION A COUPLE OF
THEM THOUGHT AGAINST THE MALE AS PARENT BECAUSE
HE WOULDN'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE
PERSONAL, PRIMARY CAREGIVER OF HIS CHILD.
AND THEN THERE WAS ONE WHO LATER BECAME MY
CHIEF WHO SAID IT'S TOTALLY ARBITRARY FROM
THE POINT OF VIEW OF THE BABY.
WHY SHOULD THE BABY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE CARE OF A SOUL SURVIVING PARENT ONLY WHEN
THAT PARENT IS FEMALE, NOT MALE?
PEOPLE WERE ASTONISHED BECAUSE IT WAS THE
FIRST TIME THAT THEN JUSTICE REHNQUIST HAD
EVER FOUND A LAW OFFENSIVE TO THE EQUAL PROTECTION
PRINCIPLE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> KATHLEEN SULLIVAN: SO THAT WAS A REMARKABLE
DECISION TO HAVE IT COME DOWN UNANIMOUSLY.
AND IT WAS A WAY OF SAYING THAT A LAW THAT
SEEMS TO GIVE WOMEN SPECIAL PRIVILEGES AND
PROTECTION CAN ACTUALLY BE DISCRIMINATORY
AGAINST WOMEN WAGE EARNERS AND SERVICE MEMBERS,
AND DISCRIMINATORY AGAINST MEN WHO ARE PLAYING
THE ROLE OF PARENT OR CARETAKER OF THE CHILDREN
AFTER A SPOUSE HAS DIED, AND IT CREATES THESE
STEREOTYPES, AND THAT'S NO DOUBT WHAT LED
JUSTICE BRENNAN, AND THE CONCURRENCE IN THE
FRONTIERO CASE THAT YOU WON SPECTACULARLY,
WHAT LOOKS LIKE BEING PUT ON A PEDESTAL MAY
SOMETIMES BE A CAGE IMPRISONING WOMEN IN OLD
STEREOTYPES.
SO BETWEEN REED AND FRONTIERO AND WIESENFELD
YOU REALLY LAID THE GROUNDWORK FOR THE LAW
THAT STARTED TO BREAK DOWN THOSE ARCHAIC STEREOTYPES.
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU IF YOU WOULD TALK ABOUT
THIS.
WHAT WAS THE ROLE OF POPULAR OPINION OR THE
EVOLVING SOCIAL CONSENSUS IN THOSE DECISIONS?
>> RUTH BADER GINSBURG: IT MADE ALL THE DIFFERENCE.
THE LITIGATION IN THE '70s WOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPOSSIBLE IN THE '60s. LET ME GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE.
JURY DUTY WAS MENTIONED THIS MORNING.
THERE WAS A CASE IN 1961, THESE WERE THE YEARS
OF THE QUOTE LIBERAL WARREN COURT.
THE CASE INVOLVED GWENDOLYN HOYT.
TODAY WE WOULD CALL HER A BATTERED WOMEN.
SHE ONE DAY HAD BEEN HUMILIATED TO THE BREAKING
POINT BY HER PHILANDERING, ABUSIVE HUSBAND.
SHE TURNED TO THE CORNER OF THE ROOM AND THERE
WAS HER YOUNG SON'S BASEBALL BAT.
AND SHE TOOK IT AND HIT HER SOUSE OVER THE
HEAD AND HE FELL AGAINST THE STONE FLOOR,
END OF THEIR ALTERCATION, AND THE BEGINNING
OF THE MURDER PROSECUTION.
THIS OCCURED IN HILLSBORO COUNTY FLORIDA,
AND AT THOSE DAYS WOMEN WERE NOT ON JURY ROLLS.
THEY COULD COME TO THE CLERKS OFFICE AND SIGN
UP, BUT OTHERWISE THEY WEREN'T THERE.
SHE WAS TRIED BEFORE AN ALL MALE JURY, AND
SHE HAD THE NOTION NOT THAT NECESSARILY SHE
WOULD BE ACQUITTED IF WOMEN WERE ON THE JURY.
BUT THE CHOICE BETWEEN MURDER AND MANSLAUGHTER,
THE WOMEN ON THE JURY MAY HAVE SWUNG IT TO
THE LESSER CRIME OF MANSLAUGHTER.
SHE WAS CONVICTED OF MURDER BY AN ALL MALE
JURY.
WHEN HER CASE GOT TO THE SUPREME COURT IN
1961, THE VIEW WAS, WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS
COMPLAINT.
WOMEN HAVE THE BEST OF BOTH WORLDS, THEY CAN
SIGN UP IF THEY WANT TO, BUT IF THEY DON'T
WANT TO SERVE, THEY DON'T HAVE TO.
THE POINT THAT OUR LAWYERS TREID TO MAKE TO
THE SUPREME COURT WAS KEEPING WOMEN OFF THE
JURY ROLLS SAYS SOMETHING ABOUT HOW THE STATE
REGARDS ITS CITIZENS.
CITIZENS HAVE OBLIGATIONS AS WELL AS RIGHTS.
AND ONE OBLIGATION IS TO BE PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION
OF JUSTICE.
SO A LAW THAT SAYS WOMEN AREN'T ON JURIES
UNLESS THEY VOLUNTEER IS SAYING THAT WOMEN
ARE EXPENDABLE.
WE DON'T NEED THEM IN THIS JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IF THEY WANT TO, WE'LL ALLOW THEM.
THE MEN, ON THE OTHER HAND, ARE ESSENTIAL.
SO WE CAN'T GIVE THEM EXEMPTIONS FROM JURY
DUTY.
THAT WAS GWENDOLYN HOYT'S CASE IN 1961. THERE
WAS A SEA CHANGE IN ATTITUDE BY THE '70s.
MORE AND MORE WOMEN WERE IN THE WORKFORCE.
IT BECAME INCREASINGLY EASIER TO CONTROL,
A WOMAN TO CONTROL HER REPRODUCTIVE CAPACITY.
PEOPLE WERE LIVING LONGER.
AND THERE WAS QUITE A HIGH DEGREE OF INFLATION.
SO THE TWO EARNER FAMILY BECAME THE IDEAL.
IT WAS THAT CHANGE THAT HAD ALREADY OCCURRED
IN SOCIETY THAT LED THE COURT AT LAST TO CATCH
UP TO THAT CHANGE.
>> KATHLEEN SULLIVAN: AND I THINK IT'S WORTH
STOPPING TO NOTE HOW REMARKABLE IT WAS THAT
YOU WON THOSE SEX DISCRIMINATION CASES IN
THE EARLY '70s, AFTER JUST A DECADE THAT THE
SUPREME COURT REFUSED TO FIND IT DISCRIMINATION
TO KEEP WOMEN OFF THE JURY ROLLS.
SO THAT'S A REMARKABLE CHANGE IN A SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME DUE VERY MUCH TO ADVOCACY AS WELL
AS SOCIAL EVOLUTION.
BUT YOU FAMOUSLY SAID ONCE THAT THE COURT
CAN'T GET OUT TOO FAR AHEAD OF SOCIAL CONSENSUS
AND POPULAR OPINION.
MAYBE THE NATION NEEDED MORE TIME TO PERCOLATE
BEFORE ROE VS. WADE WAS DECIDED. HOW DO WE
KNOW WHEN POPULAR OPINION AND SOCIAL CONSENSUS
HAS COME FAR ENOUGH? WHEN DO WE LOOK TO?
>> RUTH BADER GINSBURG: IT WASN'T SO MUCH
THAT ROE WAS AHEAD OF ITS TIME.
IT WAS REALLY THE WAY THAT THE COURT DECIDED.
IT WAS AN UNUSUAL DECISION IN THIS RESPECT.
IN ONE FELL SWOOP THE COURT MADE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
EVERY ABORTION LAW IN THE COUNTRY.
EVEN THE MOST LIBERAL STATES DIDN'T SATISFY
THE STANDARDS SET IN THAT CASE.
SO THE COURT HAD DONE IT ALL.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO WERE ADVOCATING FOR A WOMAN'S
ABILITY TO CONTROL HER OWN DESTINY, THEY RETIRED,
WHILE THE OPPOSITION MOUNTED.
NOW THEY HAD INSTEAD OF HAVING TO FIGHT IN
THE TRENCHES STATE BY STATE, SOMETIMES WINNING,
SOMETIMES LOSING, THEY HAD THIS ONE SINGLE
TARGET TO AIM AT.
THIS DECISION.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN AN EASY THING TO DO, TO
DECLARE THE TEXAS LAW THAT WAS IN FRONT OF
THE COURT UNCONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE THE ONLY
GROUND FOR ABORTION IN TEXAS AT THE TIME WAS
THE LIFE OF THE WOMAN.
NOT HER HEALTH. HER HEALTH COULD BE DEVASTATED
IT DIDN'T MATTER.
JUST HER LIFE.
THAT WAS TOO EXTREME.
THE COURT COULD HAVE SAID THAT AND PUT DOWN
ITS PEN AND THEN LET THE POLITICAL SYSTEM
REACT TO THAT.
>> KATHLEEN SULLIVAN: SO SOMETIMES THE NATURE
OF THE DECISION AND THE RATE OF CHANGE IS
JUST AS IMPORTANT AS THE COUNTRY'S READINESS
FOR CHANGE.
MAYBE WE COULD FAST FORWARD NOW TO THE TIME
YOU HAD ON THE BENCH.
YOU HAD THE REMARKABLE PRIVILEGE OF NOT ONLY
ARGUING AS AN ADVOCATE AND WINNING SOME OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT SEX DISCRIMINATION CASES
IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
YOU THEN SITTING ON THE COURT HAD THE CHANCE
TO AUTHOR SOME OF THEM.
I WONDER IF YOU COULD SHARE WITH US SOME OBSERVATIONS
ABOUT WRITING THE OPINION FOR THE COURT IN
THE VIRGINIA MILITARY INSTITUTE CASE, WHICH
HELD THAT WOMEN COULDN'T BE EXCLUDED FROM
A PUBLIC MILITARY INSTITUTE, NOT EVEN IF THERE
WAS ANOTHER SCHOOL FOR GIRLS NEARBY.
>> RUTH BADER GINSBURG: PERHAPS I SHOULD START
WITH A CASE THAT WAS 20 YEARS EARLIER.
IT WAS SUSAN VORCHHEIMER'S CASE AGAINST THE
PHILADELPHIA BOARD OF EDUCATION.
THERE WERE TWO HIGH SCHOOLS FOR GIFTED CHILDREN
IN PHILADELPHIA.
THE NAMES OF THE SCHOOLS I THINK TELL THE
STORY.
ONE WAS GIRLS HIGH.
AND THE OTHER WAS CENTRAL HIGH.
[LAUGHTER]
A YOUNG GIRL NOTICING THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THESE TWO SCHOOLS SAID I DON'T WANT TO GO
TO THE GIRLS HIGH, I WANT TO GO TO THE CENTRAL
HIGH WHERE THEY HAVE BETTER SCIENCE AND MATH
FACILITIES, A MUCH BETTER LIBRARY.
OF COURSE INFINITELY BETTER SPORTS FACILITIES.
SO SHE STARTED HER CASE IN THE FEDERAL DISTRICT
COURT AND SHE WON.
IT WENT UP ON APPEALS, AND THE COURT OF APPEALS
REVERSED TWO TO ONE.
SHE PETITIONED AND THE SUPREME COURT SPLIT
FOUR TO FOUR.
THAT MEANS YOU AUTOMATICALLY AFFIRM THE DECISION
OF THE COURT ONE STEP BELOW.
WRITE NO OPINION, IT HAS NO PRESIDENTIAL VALUE.
THE FEDERAL COURTS WERE EVENLY DIVIDED WITH
TWO IN THE LOWER COURTS ON EACH SIDE AND THE
SUPREME COURT FOUR TO FOUR.
I HAD WRITTEN THE BRIEF IN THE VORCHHEIMER
CASE BUT IT WAS ARGUED BY LOCAL COUNSEL.
AND WHEN THE VMI DECISION CAME OUT, MY DEAR
HUSBAND SAID TO ME WELL RUTH IT TOOK YOU 20
YEARS TO WIN THE VORCHHEIMER CASE, BUT YOU
FINALLY DID IT.
[APPLAUSE]
BUT THE CHANGE IN THE TIME IS INTERESTING.
BECAUSE THE NAME OF THE VMI CASE IS UNITED
STATES AGAINST VIRGINIA.
SO IT WAS OUR GOVERNMENT URGING THAT NO PUBLIC
INSTITUTION COULD EXCLUDE ON THE BASIS OF
GENDER.
THE GOVERNMENT TAKING UP THE CLAIM OF THE
WOMEN WHO WANTED TO BE ADMITTED TO VMI.
SOME PEOPLE SAID TO ME ABOUT THE VMI CASE,
WELL, WHY WOULD WOMEN WANT TO GO TO THAT SCHOOL?
WELL, I WOULDN'T WANT TO.
PERHAPS, YOU, A MAN WOULD NOT WANT TO EITHER.
BUT THERE ARE SOME WOMEN WHO SEE THAT AS THE
RIGHT PLACE FOR THEM.
AND WHO ARE FULLY EQUIPPED TO SURVIVE THE
RIGOROUS REGIME.
WHY SHOULD THEY BE HELD BACK SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY ARE WOMEN?
AND SO THE VMI CASE WAS VERY SATISFYING IN
MANY WAYS.
FOR ONE THING, THE VMI FACULTY WAS VERY MUCH
IN FAVOR OF THE ADMISSION OF WOMEN.
THE REASON SHOULD BE OBVIOUS.
IF THEY COULD INCLUDE WOMEN IN THEIR APPLICANT
POOL, THEY WOULD UPGRADE THE QUALITY OF THEIR
STUDENTS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> KATHLEEN SULLIVAN: WELL THAT WAS A REMARKABLE
DECISION AND ONE OF MANY IMPORTANT ONES YOU
WROTE ON THE COURT.
I WISH WE HAD MORE TIME TO TALK ABOUT ALL
OF THEM.
BUT MAYBE WE COULD TALK A BIT MORE BROADLY
ABOUT THE COURT ITSELF AND ABOUT THE COLLEGIALLY
WE SAW ON THAT MAGNIFICENT DISPLAY WE SAW
TODAY IN JUSTICE SOUTER'S REMARKS ABOUT YOU
AND YOUR REMARKS IN DUET WITH HIM ABOUT HOW
MUCH YOU ENJOYED BEING HIS COLLEAGUE.
BUT THE TWO OF YOU DID AGREE QUITE A BIT.
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S AN OPERA CALLED
SCALIA/GINSBURG THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN YOU AND JUSTICE SCALIA.
AND YET YOU'RE GREAT FRIENDS.
AND YOU GO TO THE OPERA TOGETHER AND YOU HAVE
COLLEGIATELY THAT I THINK YOU'VE DESCRIBED
AS BEING TRUE OF ALL THE MEMBER OF THE COURT.
SO HOW CAN IT BE THAT AS THE CLOSING DUET
OF SCALIA/GINSBURG GOES YOU CAN BE ON THE
COURT WITH PEOPLE WHO SAY TO EACH OTHER, AS
YOU AND SAID TO SING TO EACH OTHER.
WE ARE DIFFERENT, WE ARE ONE.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> RUTH BADER GINSBURG: I WOULD LIKE TO EXPLAIN
FIRST WHY THIS OPERA IS CALLED SCALIA/GINSBURG,
BECAUSE SOME OF MY FEMINIST COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID YOU COME FIRST ALPHABETICALLY! IT SHOULD
BE GINSBERG/SCALIA. I EXPLAIN THAT IN THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT SENIORITY IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
SCALIA WAS APPOINTED IN THE '80s. SO HE'S
A FEW STEPS AHEAD OF GINSBURG.
BY SENIORITY, IT'S SCALIA, GINSBURG.
THE CLOSING ARIA, WHAT IT PORTRAYS IS WE HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWS ON HOW OUR CONSTITUTION SHOULD
BE INTERPRETED.
BUT WE REVERE THE COURT AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T DO ANY DAMAGE TO IT.
SO DIFFERENT IN OUR VIEWS, BUT ONE IN OUR
REVERENCE FOR THE FEDERAL JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
>> KATHLEEN SULLIVAN: DO YOU WANT TO TELL
PEOPLE HOW THE OPERA OPENS?
WHAT THE DIFFERENCES ARE?
>> RUTH BADER GINSBURG: WELL THE OPERA IS
BORROWED FROM MANY LONG DEAD COMPOSERS.
LONG DEAD BECAUSE THERE'S NO COPYRIGHT PROBLEMS.
SO SCALIA'S OPENING ARIA IS HANDELLIAN. IT'S
A RAGE ARIA.
IT GOES THIS WAY.
THE JUSTICES ARE BLIND.
HOW CAN THEY POSSIBLY SPOUT THIS.
THE CONSTITUTION SAID ABSOLUTELY NOTHING ABOUT
THIS.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT MY ANSWERING
ARIA, IT IS YOU ARE SEARCHING FOR BRIGHT LINE
SOLUTIONS TO PROBLEMS THAT DON'T HAVE EASY
ANSWERS BUT THE GREAT THING ABOUT OUR CONSTITUTION
IT CAN EVOLVE!
[APPLAUSE]
AND THEN ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT SCENES,
AND I'M EAGER TO SEE THIS PERFORMED, IS JUSTICE
SCALIA HAS BEEN LOCKED UP IN A DARK ROOM BEING
PUNISHED FOR EXCESSIVE DISSENTING.
[LAUGHTER]
AND I COME TO HIS RESCUE ENTERING THROUGH
A GLASS CEILING.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> KATHLEEN SULLIVAN: WELL I THINK THIS IS
A FITTING NOTE ON WHICH TO END OUR CONVERSATION.
BECAUSE A REALLY IMPORTANT NEXT STEP NEEDS
TO OCCUR, THE AWARDING OF THE RADCLIFFE MEDAL.
THERE ISN'T A GLASS CEILING YOU HAVEN'T BROKEN.
AS BRILLIANT PROFESSOR, AS ORIGINATOR OF AN
ENTIRE LINE OF SCHOLARSHIP, ON GENDER DISCRIMINATION,
AS BRILLIANT LAWYER.
ALL WITHOUT ROLE MODELS.
THERE WEREN'T WOMEN FEDERAL JUDGES BEFORE
1949. AND THEN OF COURSE AS THE SECOND WOMAN
JUSTICE ON THE SUPREME COURT AND A GREAT JUSTICE,
THANK YOU FOR THE INSPIRATION YOU HAVE GIVEN
TO ALL OF US WHO ARE PRIVILEGED TO HAVE BENEFITED
FROM THE PATHWAYS YOU HAVE FORGED IN THE LAW.
AND LET ME JUST CLOSE BY ASKING YOU TO SAY
ONE LAST THING ABOUT WHAT YOU WOULD SAY TO
THE YOUNG WOMEN OF TODAY, IF SO MUCH COULD
CHANGE IN YOUR CAREER AND THROUGH YOUR CAREER,
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE MOST INSPIRATIONAL
MESSAGE YOU HAVE FOR THEM?
>> RUTH BADER GINSBURG: YOUNG WOMEN TODAY
HAVE THIS GREAT ADVANTAGE IS THAT THERE ARE
NO DOORS, NO MORE CLOSED DOORS.
THAT WAS BASICALLY WHAT THE '70s WERE ABOUT.
OPENING DOORS THAT HAD BEEN CLOSED TO WOMEN.
SO MY ADVICE, WHAT IS MY ADVICE, IS FIGHT
FOR THE THINGS THAT YOU CARE ABOUT.
BUT DO IT IN A WAY THAT WILL LEAD OTHERS TO
JOIN YOU.
THAT IS, ONE VITAL ASSET
IS A SENSE OF HUMOR.
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PUTDOWNS I HAVE TURNED
AWAY THAT WAY.
THE REMARK WAS MADE ABOUT THEN JUSTICE REHNQUIST
SAYING AT THE END OF THE MISSOURI JURY CASE.
SO MRS. GINSBERG YOU WON'T SETTLE FOR SUSAN
B. ANTHONY'S FACE ON THE NEW DOLLAR?
A PERFECT ANSWER WHICH I DIDN'T THINK OF ON
THE SPOT WOULD HAVE BEEN NO, JUSTICE REHNQUIST,
TOKENS WON'T DO.
[APPLAUSE]
>> KATHLEEN SULLIVAN: LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THANK YOU TO JUSTICE GINSBURG.
I'LL TURN IT BACK OVER TO DEAN COHEN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
I WILL SPEAK I THINK FOR EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM, IN THIS TENT, TO THANK YOU KATHLEEN
SULLIVAN FOR BEING SUCH A SPECTACULAR TEACHER
AS JUSTICE SOUTER TOLD US YOU ARE.
AND FOR BEING PART OF ANOTHER RADCLIFFE DAY,
YOU WERE ON THE PANEL WHEN WE GAVE THE MEDAL
TO MARGIE MARSHALL, AND FOR SHARING YOUR INTELLIGENCE,
YOUR WHIT, YOUR CHARM WITH US.
WE HAVE SEEN TODAY THAT YOU CAN ASK QUESTIONS
AS IMPRESSIVELY AS YOU CAN ANSWER THEM.
AND WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO YOU FOR BOTH.
SO THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
AND OF COURSE TO JUSTICE GINSBURG, THANK YOU
FOR GIVING US SUCH A MARVELOUS DAY.
YOU SO GENEROUSLY SHARED YOUR TIME, YOUR INSIGHTS,
AND YOUR WISDOM.
IT IS NOW THE MOMENT TO CONFER ON YOU THE
2015 RADCLIFFE MEDAL.
HERE IS THE CITATION.
SHE IS A PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR EQUALITY
AND A DISPASSIONATE JURIST FOR JUSTICE.
WHETHER IN THE MAJORITY OR THE MINORITY, SHE
ILLUMINATES A PATH TOWARD A SOCIETY OF GREATER
FAIRNESS AND DIGNITY.
SHE ELEVATES THE WORK OF THE COURT BY RESPECTING
HER OPPONENTS WHILE HOLDING STEADFAST TO HER
CONVICTIONS.
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG, I BESTOW UPON
YOU THIS RADCLIFFE MEDAL WITH THE DEEPEST
ADMIRATION FOR A LIFETIME OF BRILLIANT SERVICE.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]